-The president
is already ramping up
his re-election campaign
as the specter
of Robert Mueller's report
looms over him.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Trump's campaign team
is signaling to reporters
that they want to build
a massive re-election machine
with tons of money
and resources.
But as CNN reported this week,
Trump's campaign also keeps
insisting to reporters
that Trump, himself,
is in charge.
-We're getting
a rare exclusive look
inside the Trump 2020
re-election campaign
that's been humming since
his inauguration day.
We're hearing about the changes
that they've made
to better use technology,
and as CNN's chief political
correspondent Dana Bash
now reports, how even
the president's campaign manager
admits that Trump is
the communications director,
the finance director,
campaign manager,
and master of the Trump train.
-I mean, maybe
he has all those jobs
because no one else
wants those jobs.
After the last --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Remember,
after the last election,
his campaign chairman,
deputy campaign chairman,
national security adviser,
foreign policy adviser,
informal outside advisers,
and personal lawyer
all got indicted
or went to jail.
It's really hard to make
"Ocean's Twelve"
when Ocean's Eleven
is facing 15 to 20.
[ Laughter ]
If you get to job working for
Trump's re-election campaign,
they hand you an HR manual
and a jump suit.
I'm just kidding,
they don't have HR manuals.
[ Laughter ]
Also can we hear the list of
jobs Trump supposedly has again?
-Trump is the communications
director, the finance director,
campaign manager,
and master of the Trump train.
-Master of the Trump train
sounds like a fun one
they made up to keep his
attention in a meeting.
"All right, Kellyanne,
you talk to reporters,
Stephen, you're from charge
of immigration policy,
and, Donald, you get to be the
conductor of the Trump train.
Here's your official hat!"
Now, no one should assume
that Trump is going to be
easy to beat.
But as his re-Election campaign
ramps up,
he's preparing for
the political fallout
from special counsel
Robert Mueller's looming report
which could come out
any week now.
Yesterday, Trump was asked
if he would be in favor
of making Mueller's
report public,
and he insisted
that he would be,
although if you listen to
Trump's rambling answers,
it's hard to believe
that he genuinely wants
the report to come out.
-I just won an election
with 63 million votes or so --
63 million.
I got 306 electoral votes
against 223.
That's a tremendous victory.
And now somebody
just writes a report?
I think it's ridiculous.
I know that he's conflicted,
and I know that his best friend
is Comey, who's a bad cop.
I know that he put
13 highly conflicted
and, you know, very angry --
I call them angry Democrats in.
There's no collusion.
There was no collusion.
There was no obstruction.
There was no nothing.
With all of that being said,
I look forward to seeing
the report.
[ Laughter ]
-"With all that being said,"
doesn't really work
when you just said all that.
It's like if a cop
pulled you over and asked
if you'd been drinking,
you said,
"Well, officer, I had three
beers, three shots of whiskeys,
a screwdriver, a margarita,
two mai tais, a Martini,
a bottle of wine, six jello
shots, and a line of coke.
With all that being said,
I think I'm good to drive.
[ Laughter ]
But it's important to remember
that Mueller's report
is not the be-all-end-all,
and Russian collusion
is not the only crime
Trump is being investigated for.
In fact, there are multiple
law enforcement agencies
investigating virtually
every aspect of Trump's life
from his personal finances
to his business.
And this week, we got
some blockbuster reporting
suggesting that Trump
may have lied to a bank
about his net worth
to get a loan.
-"The New York Times"
is reporting that years ago,
Deutsche Bank loaned
over $2 billion
to President Trump,
even though they allegedly knew
that he was lying about
his net worth.
-The story says, "Mr. Trump
told Deutsche Bank
his net worth was about
$3 billion.
But when the bank employees
reviewed his finances,
they concluded he was worth
about $788 million.
-He inflated his net worth
by more than $2 billion.
It's like when you see a guy
on tinder who says
he speaks six languages,
and then he takes you
to Starbucks and goes,
"Can I have a Farpakieno?"
[ Laughter ]
You want a farpakieno?
Make it deuce-o."
But the craziest
part of this story
is that despite
all the red flags,
Deutsche Bank gave Trump
billions of dollars anyway.
Time after time,
the bank handed over money,
a total well over $2 billion
to a man who nearly all other
banks had deemed untouchable.
Aside from his history
of defaults,
he was an attractive borrower.
That's an insane sentence --
A history of defaults
is what makes you
an unattractive borrower.
It's like an episode
of "dateline" that starts
"he was an attractive husband,
aside from his history
of murder."
[ Ominous music plays ]
[ Laughter ]
The story is such
a perfect microcosm
of how the game is rigged
for people like Donald Trump.
The guy allegedly lied
about his net worth
and defaulted on loans,
yet a major bank was happy
to give him $2 billion.
Compare that to
the 2008 financial crisis,
when conservatives were furious
at the idea
that President Obama
was going to help out
struggling homeowners who
couldn't pay their mortgages.
Conservatives said at the time
that if you took out a mortgage
you couldn't afford,
it was your fault.
You might even remember
this famous rant on CNBC
by a guy named Rick Santelli.
This is the rant that is
credited by many people
with starting the Tea Party
movement.
-The government is promoting
bad behavior.
How about this, President
and new administration --
Why don't you put up a website
to have people vote
on the Internet as a referendum
to see if we really want to
subsidize the losers' mortgages.
This is America!
How many of you people
want to pay
for your neighbors' mortgage
that has an extra bathroom
and can't pay their bills?
Raise their hand.
How about we all --
[ Audience booing ]
Agh! President Obama,
are you listening?
-To answer your question,
No, he wasn't,
because we used to
have a president
who didn't spend all day
watching cable TV.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now if you go on TV and say,
"President Trump,
are you listening?"
He would call in
five minutes later.
[ As Trump ]
Heard you loud and clear.
And yet, despite the culture
of criminality and corruption
surrounding the president,
Republicans are already
falling in line
with his re-election bid,
even ones to expressed
reservations about him.
Take, for example,
Texas Congressman Will Hurd,
who has criticized Trump's
demand for a border wall.
Hurd has cast himself
as a champion
of bipartisan compromise.
In fact, in 2017,
he famously went on
a 36-hour road trip
with Democrat Beto O'Rourke.
They even live streamed
parts of it on Facebook.
-After 36 hours and 1,600 miles
from San Antonio
to Washington in a Chevy Impala,
Democrat Beto O'Rourke
and Republican Will Hurd
have become a little closer.
-♪ We're the best of friends ♪
on the road, they found a mutual
appreciation for country music,
fast food --
-Whataburger unites us all.
-And topics that you'll never
find in any buddy movie.
-We need to be bringing more
people on the healthcare rolls,
not fewer.
-Building a wall from
sea to shining sea
is the most expensive
and least effective way
to do border security.
-Wow, that is the most
policy heavy road trip
since that documentary
about legalizing weed
starring Cheech & Chong.
[ Laughter ]
The road trip went viral,
and Beto even declined to help
Hurd's Democratic opponent
in 2018 as a sign
of their friendship,
so naturally, when Hurd
was asked earlier this month
if he would vote for his friend,
Beto, over the president,
he was repeatedly criticized.
Hurd said he would definitely
vote for Donald Trump.
-Who would you vote for between
Beto O'Rourke and Donald Trump?
-My plan is to vote for
the Republican nominee.
-Man, you know it's bad
when you can't even say the name
of the guy you're voting for.
Republicans are gonna have to
print out lawn signs
that say "Republican nominee,
whoever that is, 2020."
[ Laughter ]
Also, you're going to toss Beto
after all you've been through?
Because if you went on
a road trip and ate Whataburger,
I can only imagine fart cloud
you two shared.
[ Laughter ]
Right-wing pundits who
distanced themselves from Trump
are falling in line, too,
like former Fox News host,
Glenn Beck.
Beck spent most of his years
as one of the most unhinged
voices on Fox,
warning that nefarious forces
were destroying the country,
and trying to prove
that Obama was a dictator
by circling random letters
on a chalkboard
like he was playing a dickhead
version of the Jumble.
-Obama, the left,
internationalists,
graft,
ACORN-style organizations,
revolution,
and hidden agenda.
O...L...I...
G...A...R...H.
[ Laughter ]
One letter is missing.
And then tie them all together
into one word.
Oligarch.
The one that's missing...
is "Y."
-No.
No. That's not -- That's not
the letter you're missing.
You spelled oligarchy without
a "C."
That's oligarhy.
You're closer to spelling
Olive Garden.
[ Laughter ]
Now, now...
[ Applause ]
In 2016, Beck seemed to have
a change of heart.
HE apologized for extremist
rhetoric,
said he would not vote
for Trump,
and even told
"The New York Times,"
"I think he could be one
of the most dangerous presidents
to ever come into
the oval office."
At the time, many suspected
this was all just an act
to rebrand himself,
and when he went on Fox News
this week to talk about 2020,
he finally dropped the act.
-I will tell you this --
if the Republicans don't win
in this next election,
I think we are officially
at the end of the country
as we know it.
-Oh, my God. Hold on, you guys.
He's on Fox News...
[ Laughter ]
...talking about the end
of the United States...
which can mean only one thing --
"F.U."
[ Laughter ]
And I'm sorry, but we're not --
[ Cheers and applause ]
We're not taking
political advice --
Nobody wants to take
political advice
from divorced Santa Claus
over here.
And we can tell he's pandering
to Trump
because he's started to
dress like The Colonel.
[ Laughter ]
Republicans are falling in line
with Trump's re-election bid
despite the culture
of corruption
and criminality around him.
So many of his closest
associates have been indicted,
and every aspect of his personal
life is being investigated.
At this point,
in order not to find a crime,
you'd have to be a --
-Bad cop.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪